en france 7 millions neuf cent soixante
dix mille habitants n'ont pas de bureau
de poste dans leur commune pourtant
avant la poste et est un vecteur de vie
dans les campagnes bien plus que de la
distribution de courrier
regardez victorine par exemple factrice
à corgoloin en côte-d'or en 1978 ah oui
aimable taurine comme l'appellent les
villageois ronde et services acheter du
pain aider à rédiger du courrier sur
tout être à l'écouté la poste service
public par excellence jusque dans les
coins les plus reculés de france
sauf qu'à la fin des années 80 les
premières fermetures de bureaux sont
annoncés pour bien comprendre les enjeux
passons par le village de glay dans le
tout en 1988
voici la position du maire c'est celle
du village qui s'en va si la poche de
sang valait une classe ferme
le village va nous on va mourir parce
que blais et pas du tout un village qui
m'a loin de là mais on le vit peu à peu
à peu de sa substance et celle du
représentant départemental de la poste
le trafic actuel se situe à peu près à
une opération par heure que nous le chef
d'entreprise qui donne aux hommes
d'affaires comme ça accepterait une
situation dans le sens de la vie dans le
rural contre services publics
déficitaires
partout ou presque la résistance passe
par des grèves et des manifestations
la stratégie de l'entreprise trouver le
juste milieu entre rentabilité et
couverture du territoire
en 1996 la france comptait 17 mille
bureaux de poste ce nombre est tombé à
14 milles en 2005 selon 60 millions de
consommateurs et à 9000 en 2017
en compensation des bureaux fermés
l'entreprise a déployé des besoins de
poste parfois de simples bornes dans des
supermarchés loin du bureau des ptt du
village
[Musique]